[Musique]
ban
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ayrault
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tha
à
ap
[Musique]
à
depuis
[Musique]
à
paris
[Musique]
à
ma vie
m
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allo
je suis leur gosse je suis une danseuse
j'ai toujours été une danseuse suis
désolé danser parler oui c'était pas
comme ça dans les répétitions arrête là
tu le texte lola ok je suis j'étais
toujours en danseuse mon premier amour
était la danse classique
j'ai passé six jours par semaine j'ai
progressé rapidement ma manière de danse
et techniques et pleine de passion mais
aussi j'ai eu des grosses fesses
peut-être vous les avez vous moi et mes
grosses fesses n'avons pas toujours été
bien accueilli sur la scène en
particulier la scène de danse classique
je n'ai pas laissé m'arrêter j'ai créé
ma propre compagnie de danse et j'ai
dansé et puis j'ai eu 30 ans dans le
monde de danse 30 ans et la fin de votre
carrière
mais pour moi je n'étais pas prête à
arrêter de jouer et à ce moment là où
j'ai plongé dans le monde du burlesque
mais grosses fesses ont plongé les
premières c'est vrai le burlesque
parfois appelée cabaret est une niche
comme artistiques dans l'air du temps
un style de danse sensuelle créatif et
novateur depuis 1840 le burlesque est
devenu une source riche de danse de
musique et de comédie
les danseuses perla sont connus pour
s'habiller dans les costumes élaborés
qui seront éliminés lors de leurs
performances
mais la nudité n'est pas obligatoire
le burlesque est souvent appelée lattes
de la shinari le burlesque existent
aujourd'hui pour reconstruire une idée
plus inclusif ce qui est sexy
le burlesque reconstruit les gens il
nous apprend que tous les corps tous les
âges tous les cinq sont sexy ils
contestent les normes sociales de ce qui
est désirable et en 30 ans il propose
l'idée radical que vous êtes aimable et
séduisant séduisant comme vous êtes que
vous n'avez pas besoin ni de régime ni
de routine d'exercices ni de sucre
surgery plastique mais que vous avez
juste besoin de continuer à respirer et
à croire il m'a changé cela m'a aidé à
aimer la terre de mes fesses et l'accord
de mes hanches
je me sens impuissant et sexy confidence
j'ai arrêté d'essayer de me faire une
idée de ce qu'est une danseuse je suis
une danseuse plus de trente ans plus de
40 kg couverte de tatouages
ma présence dans le monde en tant que
danseuse ouvre des portes à beaucoup des
gens et m'a conduit il ya deux ans et
demi en france à saint brieuc
rapidement j'ai proposé des cours du
burlesque dans une mjc
ensuite le burlesque reconstruit mes
élèves
d'ailleurs une de mes élèves a dit la
couverte du burlesque et la découverte
d'une danse qui mène au co ou ce qu'on
est capable d'être sous un autre angle
et une autre a dit bref tout devient
possible
on brise les barrières que l'on s'est
érigé en consomme
je dis à mes étudiants
la confiance est la chose la plus sexy
d'une personne et vous si vous n'avez
pas confiance en vous je peux vous
donner la mienne
j'en ai assez à partager
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah ah
oh
tous
[Musique]
bah
à
[Musique]
un homme
hu
[Applaudissements]